[Music]
et has learned
Demi Lovato's team staged an
intervention for the singer about a
month ago urging her to go to rehab she
rejected the plan and overdosed Tuesday
morning at her home in the Hollywood
Hills this afternoon authorities
released the 911 call made from Demi's
home multiple sources tell et that just
hours before Demi od'd she attended a
birthday party at saddle ranch Chop
House in West Hollywood
we're told the partying extended into
the early hours of Tuesday morning at
Demi House so what's next for the singer
[Music]
well Demi's loved ones are hoping she'll
go to rehab and resume her recovery
routine which apparently helped her stay
clean and sober for six years I take
care of my mental health I see a
therapist two days a week the most
important thing is that I stick to my
routine as much as I can which is
getting in the gym eating healthy as
much as best as I can the issue is that
really in the last six months and her
starting to disengage slowly from
recovery and then obviously using to
this extent I have a healthy support
system around me so I do everything that
it takes to maintain a happy healthy
lifestyle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]